معركه ماسك مستمره مجزره وظيفيه وشكى
وصاحبه ولجين عمران تكشف لتفاعلكم تفاصيل
دبي لينك اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
تطورات واحداث متسارعه بتشهدها قضيه تويتر
وال الماسك اللي من اول يوم استحوذ فيه
على تويتر مضيع وقت ابدا في عرض الحائط كل
الشكوى والانتقادات لطالته بسبب قراره فرض
رسوم 8$ للحفاظ على العلامه الزرقاء
للحسابات الموثقه فالقرار دخل حيز التنفيذ
في التحديث الجديد لنظام باجهزه ابل واعلن
عن بدء الاشتراك بالميزه وبدات تنفيذ في
الولايات المتحده وكندا واستراليا
ونيوزيلندا والمملكه المتحده بمجرد ما
تكتب الان في متجر التطبيقات تويتر وتدخل
على التطبيق راح تشوف الرساله اللي
شايفينها امامكم الان وفيها كاتب تويتر عن
ميزات الاشتراك في تويتر بلو مقابل ثمانيه
دولارات شهريا واللي بتضمن تقليل عدد
الاعلانات والقدره على نشر مقاطع فيديو
بمده اطول من السابق ومحتوى اكثر انتائيه
ما يتضمن حمايه المستخدم من
والبط وطبعا ماسكه عبر السيل من التغريدات
اكد على تمسكه بالقرار لو ايش ما صار وذكر
ميزات العلامه الزرقاء بدايه من التزام
تويتر بالاشراف على المحتوى من دون اي
تغيير وكمان حصول صانعي المحتوى على مدخول
مادي من خلال محتواهم اللي بينشروه مرورا
باضافه ميزه النص الطويل في التغريدات
والابتعاد عن اللجوء لخاصيه النودز
وتصويرها ووضعها في التغريده هو الامر
اللي وصفوا ماسك بالسخيف وانتهاء بمقاطع
الفيديو اللي يمكن تحميل مده اطول منها
وبدقه اعلى الى مثلا الطولها بيصير مثلا
42 دقيقه بدقيقه 1080 بالاضافه الى تحسين
عمليات البحث اللي وصفها انها بتذكره
بالطرق القديمه وعد بتحسينها على الثور
وعلى فكره هذا مو القرار الوحيد اللي
وماسك ودخل تويتر او دخلته وتويتر في
دوامه كبيره ففي كمان قرار الشركات
الكبيره المعلنه في تويتر عن انسحابهم
للمنصه ومقاطعتها بالاضافه الى تسريحه
الموظفين من الخدمه ففعلا ماسك صرف نصف
موظفي شركه تويتر يعني 3700 موظف والمسك
بررت تنفيذ القرار بانه حط كل اللوم على
انخفاض الايرادات الهائل بسبب الضغوط
والسحاب الشركات المعلنه من تويتر وقال
انه ما عنده خيار ثاني لان الشركه جلسه
تخسر 4 مليون دولار في اليوم واضاف ماسك
انه صرف لي الموظفين اللي تم تسريحهم
تعويض ثلاثه اشهر وهو زياده 50% عن
القانون يعني هو عاطيهم حقهم وزياده بحسب
رايه طبعا عمليات الفصل الجماعي اللي صارت
خلت احد مؤسسي تويتر واللي هو جاك دور
سيخرج عن صمته ويحط اللوم على نفسه في
اللي جو- بيصير وقال ان هو المسؤول عن هذا
الشيء لان هو كبر تويتر بسرعه كبيره
واعتذر للناس واكد انهم اقوياء ومارينيين
وراح يلاقوا طريقه يخرجوا فيها من صعوبه
الموقف ودور سيمو الوحيد اللي علق فالمفوض
السامي للامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان
والكرتون ارسل رساله مفتوحه لمسك فيها
دروس لحمايه حريه التعبير ووصف لجالس
بيصير في تويتر ببدايه غير مشجعه وحط
مجموعه من المبادئ اللي لازم توتير يلتزم
فيها مثل حريه التعبير هو الشفافيه
والخصوصيه ورفض خطاب الكراهيه والتميز
وطبعا موظفي تويتر المفصولين مسكتوا عن
اللي صار وفي معلومات كشفت عنها شبكه فوكس
نيوز الامريكيه وقالت فيها ان الموظفين
راح يرفعوا الدعوه قضائيه ضد ماسك لانه
اللي صار هو تجاوز للقانون الفيدرالي لانه
ماسك او تويتر ما بعرف لهم اشعار قبل
المده القانونيه اللازمه ومع ازمه
الموظفين زي ما ذكرت تويتر او زي ما انا
ذكرت سابقا في بدايه حديث اليوم تويتر
بواجه حملات مقاطعه كبيره من الشركات ويوم
عن يوم بيزيد عددها فمن بعد جانر الموتور
اللي وقفت اعلانات السابقه في تويتر في
شركات كثيره جديده اعلنت ايقاف الاعلانات
مؤقتا كمان منها بنقول فايز في اودي في
ديزني في مازدا في كوكاكولا وغيرها كمان
ايضا
كل فتره بنسمع عن قصه مؤلمه لزواج
القاصرات في اليمن ونوها جميل علي حيدر
طفله يمنيه عمرها عشر سنوات ضحيه جديده من
ضحايا زواج القاصرات في اليمن تم تزويجها
من بعد تزوير وثائقها الرسميه وتحديدا
عمرها من قبل والدها والقصه ان الطفله نهى
عائشه مع امها وزوج امها وسافرت مع زوج
امها علشان تشوف ابوها وتتعرف عليه لانها
ما بتعرفه ابدا وابوها زوجها من بعد ما
زور عمرها في الوثائق الرسميه وبعد شهور
من البحث عنها اكتشفوا الموضوع وتم القبض
على الاب والزوج والامين الشرعي وقدره
المحكمه بفسخ عقد الزواج واعاده البنت
لامها وهذي القصه عملت غضب واسعه بين
الاوساط اليمنينيه وصدرها هاشتاج اكبر
جريمه بحق الطفوله من الصوت والناس طالبوا
بمعاقبه كل من له يد في حرمانها من
طفولتها
مسلسل تلفزيون الواقع دبي بالانجليزي محور
حديث الناس وعامل جد الكبير بدا عرضه في
27 اكتوبر وبحسب نتفليكس حصل المسلسل على
130000 ساعه مشاهده خلال الاسبوع الماضي
وكان من ضمن قائمه الاكثر مشاهده كمان
المسلسل
[موسيقى]
المسلسل بدا عرضه وبدات ردات الفعل
المتباينه المختلفه في ناس شافت في نوع من
الافعال السطحيه والطرف وتشويه لسوره دبي
المراه لكن كمان في نفس الوقت في ناس حبه
العمل وكانت انه يا جماعه لا تحمل العمل
فوق ما يحتمل هو مجرد مسلسل ترفيهي احنا
معانا اليوم نورتنا في استوديو اعلاميه
لجين عمران احدى بطلات مسلسل تلفزيون
الواقع دبي لينك وهي كمان راح تتكلم على
الانتقادات التي مسلسل ومشاركتها اصلا في
هذه التجربه الجديده اصلا عليها اهلا فيك
معنا لجين اهلا وسهلا يعطيك العافيه الله
يعافيك اول شيء يعني ايش اللي خلاكي تدخلي
هذا المجال اصلا كنت متردده اكثر من مره
بس بعدين لما جلست مع او شو كان شركه
المنتجه بس لما جلس بعدين شفت ثقتهم لطفهم
همم رغبتهم الجديديه وهمم يعني يكون معهم
موجود بالبرنامج
قلت ليش لا الفكره اصلا كانت موجوده سابقا
احنا عملنا حلقه بايلوت لصالح قناه ام بي
سي بس صارت ظروف وشقه الظروف انه احنا ما
نعرض الحلقه الفايلوت ولا نكمل في المشروع
فلم عن حياه لجين نفسهم صحيح انا حياتي
انا والعائله والاصدقاء وكان فيها رسائل
كثير رائعه جدا يعني لو حتى عرضت الان
الحلقه ما هي همم مربوطه لا بزمن ولا
مربوطه باحداث معينه او مكان معين همم فلم
العرض عليه مره ثانيه شفت نتفليكس همم
منصه انترناشونال هتوصلني لا لفل مختلف لا
مشاهدين مختلفين فقلت هذه فرصه بالنسبه لي
لسه في جزء بالعالم الغرب ساره ما يعرفوا
الصوره الحقيقيه للمراه العربيه بشكل عام
والمراه السعوديه بشكل خاص لسه شايفين هي
مقموعه ما لها صوت مسموع غير مثقفه ما لها
راي والى اخره
لا يمكن تعتمد على نفسها فانا حاولت انه
من خلال مشاركه هذه ابين الصوره الصح
المغلوطه عند الغرب ده والحمد لله النتيجه
كانت مذهله بالنسبه لي ومرضيه ومثل ما
تمنيت بس ايش رايك في الكلام اذا اللي
بيتقال بما انك ذكرتي هذه النقطه انه لا
المسلسل طلع صوره مشوهه للمراه اللي
بتعتمد على زوجها اللي
تخليتي عن زميلاتك في العمل ابدا انا ما
تخليت على احد صار مسؤول عن نفسه اوكي
وبعدين همم
مثل حياتنا حياتنا هتشوف فعلا المراه
المعتمده على زوجها المراه المعتمده على
نفسها المراه المستقله المراه
المسلسل الموجوده هل انت بتشوفيها ولا
فيها هل هذه النماذج موجوده ولا هي مبالغه
هي موجوده موجوده في عالم بس انا دائما
بنحاول نتغطى وراء بعض
وراء الشمس بس واقعا هذه النماذج موجوده
موجوده الحقيقي وموجود المزيف وموجود
الزين وموجود الشين بس احنا للاسف يعني
لما يطلع برنامج همم ريالتي لازم الكلبر
اذا كان الكلب رايح فتح يقول لك متصنعيني
يا اخي طيب ما فهمناكم يعني بس هذا
الواقعنا في كل الالوان هل كان في سكربت
او مثلا اعطوكم الكلام اللي ينقال او
القصص اللي راح تصير ابدا هذا اللي صار
كله تصرفات طبيعيه يعني تصرفات ذاتيه من
كل شخص حسب طبيعه حسب شخصيته همم وهذه
واللي اكيد لك مليون بالميه عني انا الناس
اليوم انت تعرفيني من زمان من خلال السوشل
ميديا او صداقتنا شفتي شيء مختلف عن
شخصيتي بالواقع همم بالمسلسل او البرنامج
لا هو انت طلعت الملاك بينهم بالعكس هو
انت طلعتي اكثر واحده يعني
اكثر شيء سويتيني
اكثر
ههه
على فكره بعضهم بعد التصوير يكلموني
يكلموني ترى كذا كذا
بعطيهم ارشادات اذا حبه بس همم في النهايه
انا بالنسبه لي علي من شخصيتي علي من دوري
انا ماني مسؤول عن الاخرين اوكي طب بس هو
كان الطريق اللي حط لنا هي المسلسل انه
حياه المليونير كلهم كل اللي موجودين في
المسلسل هم مليونيريه المفروض
يقدر اي احد عنده سته اصفار في حسابك هو
مليونير لا يعني اكيد كنا عندنا ست اصفار
بس همم ما نعتبر مقارنه بالناس انا فيه
كثير اغنى منه بمليون مره بمراحل بس كمان
الغني ما راح يجي يقول عن نفسه اوكي
همم
نعمه رب العالمين ولكن ما حيطلع اي مشهد
اقول انا غنيه انا عندي انا مليونير بس في
ناس اكثر
وانا اقول الحمد لله
كانت مثلا
انت الوالده من البحرين بطياره خاصه هل
هذا شيء انت دائما بتسويه لانه برضو بعد
النصح يقولوا واو احنا زي ما بنركب
السياره هي راحت اخذت الطياره مو دائما
لما تحصل لي الفرصه يعني لما كنت اروح على
مهرجان جولان نعم اروح طائره خاصه في
اتفاق بيني وبين شركه جتكس انه يكون في
جانب ترويجي وهذا طبيعي ما راح اخبيه
وايضا في مصلحه يعني انا ما اسوي دعايه
يعني انا ما راح اخذها نقدا انا هاخذها
مقابل رحلات رحلات اوكي
بالنسبه لي فرصه حتى الموجود عندي في رحله
اني انا اروح اجيب امي وكان على فكره عيد
الام انا عملتها مش رايحه ولا جايباتها بس
كده ايوه اوكي طب هل انتم اصحاب فعلا في
الحقيقه اللي موجودين في المسلسل لا طبعا
انا اتعرف عليهم من خلال ال- همم
في مشاكل خاصه
وما في احد محسوب على احد مثلا
ونقله على دبي جديده فقلت لها ذكرتيني اول
ما نقلت بس اهم شيء اهلك قراب منك يقدروا
يزوروكي هنا جاءت الصدف انه اخذنا محو
الحديث انه قالت لي علاقتي مقطوعه بامي
هنا حتى الكروم والشركه الانتاج التفاجه
وما كان يعرف عن هذه النقطه فهذه حقيقيه
واقعيه 100% وفعلا من واقع رغبه بداخل
حبيت اني اساعدها لانه انا بالنسبه لي امي
جنتي وناري ما استغني عنها في حياتي
من اولادك يعني همم الله لا يحرم احد يعني
همم من احد يحبه بس اذا كمان بدي ارجع
اسالك على كمان اللاين حقك في المسلسل او
دورك او كيف بنقول حياتك في المسلسل يعني
بعد الناس كمان قالوا انه ظهور اخوك معك
مازن قالوا انه حرام مازن انك انت قلت انه
مازن ما بيشتغل وانه انت بتشرف
والله
الحمد لله
واليوم دوام اه ما شاء الله ايه الحمد لله
رب العالمين مبروك الله يبارك فيك لا بس
هذا الواقع وحال واقع حال شباب وشابات كثر
تخرجوا ومو ملاقين وظيفه ويعانوا لانه مش
محصلين وظيفه ااه بس هذا الواقع ليش اخبيه
ليش اقول لا والله اخوي ما شاء الله مدير
شركه وهو متخرج لا الولد صار له ثلاث
سنوات يدور على وظيفه لانه اخو لوجين
عمران الناس متوقعين اكيد
احاول ادور له وظيفه فيما يخص مجال صحيح
يعني البعض جاب مشهد لما جايبه ياخذ
200,000 اكيد اكثر من 200,000 اخذ لي اياه
بس انا ابغى يحس بقيمه الشيء ساره اللي
ياخذ الشيء تقولي جمل زي كده مثلا
كيف تتفشخر علينا
بس انا ماني من هذا النوع عندي انا حسابي
معها انتظر احد يعطيني فرصه يعني اتفشخر
الشوف اليوم ارخص شيء واسهل شيء اي احد
يقدر والله الحسابات السوشيال ميديا كلها
شغاله وانا اقدر اعمل
كانت عندي بالبيت الاسبوع الماضي كان ممكن
ما صورت همم دخلت غرفه للدرسين قالت لي
ممكن انادي زوجي يشوف غرفتك كانت ان هي
جاءت لي عمري ما شفتك صورتها قلت لها هذه
الغرفه مسويه مش للناس انا مستمتعه فيها
مش عشان الناس يستمتعوا فيها بس ما عندي
مانع تطلع اذا كان يحتاج ظهور اذا رجعنا
بالوقت هل بتشارك في المسلسل الثاني او
ندمانه لا طبعا
حسيت انك ندمانه
لاول مره على تويتر انا اشوف لجين
للناس
انت عمرك
دائما مجامله من الدرجه الاولى بس اذا ما
عندي كلمه كويسه اقدمها ما احبها
عن الناس اللي موجودين الاخرين في العمل
والحدود وقلتي انا ضيفه
وانت صورتك اول صوره في البوستستر صحيح
يمكن لانه مقارنه الباقي الشخصيات قد اكون
انا الاقدام او الاكبر او الاشهر ولكن انا
بالنسبه لي صحيح ضيفه شوفي مشاهدي ايوه
انا لاني
همم
على عدد السنوات
ظهري عمري ما دخلت في خلاف ولا عندي نيه
ادخل في خلاف ما احد مش انا مش شخصيتي
اللي تواجه وتتخانقك وتعلي صوتها هل في
جزء ثاني هيكون المفروض مبدئيا وحسب ما
سمعته قالت العصفور راح يكون في
سعودي برلينغ اه حبيبتي
ساكنين بالسعوديه طبعا فكل بلد اتوقع
هيكون فيه اكثر منجن اوكي حسب ما سمعت بس
ما اعرف مدى مصداقيه الخبر اوكي سؤال كلنا
في عيد ميلادك قلت فجاه انه اه تحيه لزوجي
وكذا ايوه صار كل احد يبعث يقول زوجها من
زوجها فين يشتغل
لا نجاوب بعد الهواء حبيبتي ههه
ما انت حابه تشاركي الناس شيء لانه الناس
فجاه تفاجات انه ابدا لجين انا احترم
خصوصيه زوجي ابنتي ابني اذا ما عندهم رغم
انهم يظهرون فانا احترم خصوصيتهم هذا امي
بتطلع ابوي
اختي اسيل بس اختي الصغيره مثلا ما عندها
نيه
احترم خصوصياتهم كل واحد عنده شخصيه وكل
اللي قرر مش انا اقرر بالنيابه عنه طيب
بالتوفيق في الزواج شكرا
قلب من عندي في رسائل ههه حب مشاهدينا
كانت معنا الاعلاميه السعوديه لجين عمران
شكرا لك
امس قصدي الستار على مسيره المدافع
الاسباني جيرارد بيكيه بعد 18 سنه من
اللعب مع فريق برشلونه نهايه كانت بالدموع
في مشهد مؤثر وتفعل كنتم تفاعل كبير كان
في من الجمهور اللي كان حاضر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تعرفنا
شو رايك
[موسيقى]
حلقه اليوم انا اعود والقي لكم غدا ان شاء
الله في امان الله
[موسيقى]